solely by sponsorship since 1980
whatever 89 it's just kind of a kind of
a look behind the peek behind the
curtain oh by the way shout-out to my
daughter Maggie for kind of redoing the
room down here I very much appreciated
she has done a tremendous job kind of
setting things up in a way that I
couldn't and and here's what we're going
to do the thing that we do in the first
week of the season y'all who he played
for because there's been a degree of
player movement here in the pandemic and
I want to see look it's baby I'll see if
the Chuckster has been paying attention
oh yeah Danny do you think everyday
calls me text me tells me who can see
where it keeps me informed no cuz he is
most of the time you are if you won't
get was right time you are very
confident and Chuck and all pregnant
each other than their one right all
right here we go super cops here are you
ready all we all all quarantine all
right here we go are we ready first one
Tyler Johnson Chuckster do we play for
the Brooklyn Nets Bing Bing Bing Bing
Atta baby
totally one for one okay
I don't think that's ever had a swindler
who he play for
[Music]
big mommy Oh No he used to he used to
yep so you're one out of two hey Chuck
hey Chuck if you get one more right I
will send this to Reno that's a little
gift for you to gamble with okay did you
get one more right thank you for thank
you for putting the pressure on in there
general
player number three is Corey Brewer this
is our Oklahoma City oh now it's so
close Sacramento
all right step up maybe you are feeling
the heat well are you gonna are you
gonna raise this bulletin board Shaq the
lower chucks I can send you that fake
buddies give up - Jack give up two
stacks
Tyler Zeller who he played for Chuck's
[Music]
the Milwaukee Bucks oh so close again
the Senate Birds
now we used to play football 2020 before
all right oh no what are you what do you
got what do you got now check all right
the last player this is a this is a who
this guy this guy's been on this on this
show so many times Anthony Tolliver fit
Serato rappers
your money is Satan check the Memphis
Grizzlies Kenny I don't know about the
way that you have had that regular phone
call Chuck when it comes to who he plays
sickness that was but you man you did
get the first one right Tyler Johnson
call fools go or he's been gravely at
all with you guys been been wonderful to
see you again shad Kenny Chuck let's do
it again next Thursday well says okay
I'll so I'll take that as a yes we'll
see you all next week
here idea